hi
i'm dylan beatty on march 25th i'm going
to be hosting nbc manchester
it's a free one day one track software
developer conference
streaming live on youtube to mark one
year of ndc
online events we've invited some of the
best speakers from around the world to
share their insight and experience with
you
across a whole range of topics from
development culture and tdd
to the latest developments around blazer
and dotnet 5.
as well as our fantastic lineup of
speakers we're going to be running
giveaways and prize draws throughout the
day
we're going to be talking to some
special guests from the manchester tech
community
and we're going to be hosting a special
online edition of dot net rocks
with richard campbell and carl franklin
we know you miss in-person events
we miss them too nbc will be back as
soon as it's safe for us to do so
and rest assured we will be bringing the
ndc roadshow to manchester
in 2022. until then come and hang
out with us online connect with our
community of speakers and technology
experts from around the world
bring questions bring curiosity bring
coffee
let's make this something awesome that's
nbc manchester 2021
a free live online developer conference
march the 25th we'll be streaming live
from 9 a.m uk time
check us out at youtube.com ndc
conferences
don't forget to like and subscribe and
we'll see you on the internet
take it easy